sie werden auch bunkerbrecher genannt
die Taurus Marschflugkörper Raketen mit
GPS-Navigation die Ziele in bis zu 500
km Entfernung angreifen können die
Bundeswehr soll rund 600 von ihnen
besitzen doch Taurus Systeme in die
Ukraine zu liefern da haben Kanzler und
Verteidigungsminister bedenken sie
fürchten eine Eskalation des Krieges
denn mit diesen Waffen könnte die
Ukraine auch Ziele in Russland Erreichen
der Zeitpunkt für eine Entscheidung ist
für uns noch nicht gekommen wir sind
nicht die einzigen die nicht liefern
auch unsere amerikanischen Verbündeten
liefern diese Marschflugkörper nicht
Deutschlands Nato-Partner Großbritannien
und Frankreich liefern diese Art von
Raketen wenn auch keine Taurus die FDP
fordert das auch von Deutschland es wäre
höchste Zeit so Strack Zimmermann eine
Debatte wie wir sie im vergangenen Jahr
immer wieder hatten sollte angesichts
der Dramatik in der Ukraine aufhören
auch die Grünen wie
verteidigungspolitikerin Agnieszka
Burger zeigen sich offen für Lieferung
weitreichender Lenkwaffen mittlerweile
gibt es auch in der Kanzlerpartei immer
mehr Befürworter wir haben das
Versprechen mit unseren NATO-Partnern
gegeben solange zu helfen wie notwendig
wir merken gerade dass die Offensive
stockt weil die Russen die Zeit genutzt
haben eben entsprechende Stellungen
auszubauen auch Logistikketten
aufzubauen und vor dem Hintergrund macht
es Sinn jetzt mit den Lenkwaffen auf
diese Logistikketten und vor allem auf
die Munitionsdepots abzuziehen fest
steht die Debatte um deutsche
Marschflugkörper für die Ukraine nimmt
Fahrt auf und der Druck auf die
Bundesregierung eine Entscheidung zu
fällen steigt
Roderich Kiesewetter ist zu uns im
Studio gekommen
CDU-Bundestagsabgeordneter und Mitglied
im Auswärtigen Ausschuss guten Morgen
ganz herzlich willkommen guten Morgen
Frau von beidenfels
Bundesverteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius hat gesagt die Lieferung von
Taurus Marschflugkörpern habe keine
Priorität warum wollen Sie Taurus an die
Ukraine liefern es kommt ja jetzt
Bewegung rein auch durch Druck der Union
und der ein oder anderen
Koalitionspartei es ist eine falsche
Einschätzung Zusagen es stellt sich
gegenwärtig nicht es ist ein ungeheuerer
Zeitdruck da die Ukraine hat keine Luft
Überlegenheit und verhindert eine
Ausweitung des Krieges und es ist eine
Frage des Vertrauens in die Ukraine dass
sie die Ziele bekämpft die nötig sind
und das bedeutet ein Abschneiden der
russischen Versorgungslinie von der Krim
das kann Taurus viel besser als alles
andere und vor allen Dingen schützt es
Menschenleben und verhindert eine
Ausweitung des Krieges dann schauen wir
vielleicht noch mal auf die technische
Machbarkeit der Taurus Marschflugkörper
wird von Kampfjets abgeschossen bei der
Bundeswehr z.B Tornado oder Eurofighter
hat die Ukraine überhaupt geeignete
Flugzeuge die Franzosen liefern gerade
eine vergleichbare Waffe und passender
24 also su24 an die Ukraine hat kaum
mehr eigene Luftfahrzeuge deswegen
müssen wir das in Kombination mit einer
kampfjetkoalition sehen an der
Deutschland nicht teilnimmt aber
beispielsweise Luxemburg und auf der
anderen Seite geht es darum die
verfügbaren Flugzeuge der ukrainischen
Luftwaffe zu ertüchtigen und das ließe
sich aus der Ferne machen und ist eine
abstandswaffe ist mit bis 500 km
Reichweite genau das ist ja das Argument
von Kanzler Scholz und
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
die Bedenken haben und sich bislang
dagegen aussprechen gerade wegen der von
Ihnen angesprochenen Reichweite von 500
km damit könnte man auch russisches
Staatsgebiet treffen haben sie keinerlei
Bedenken oder Sorge dass dadurch der
Konflikt eskaliert das ist ein
Scheinargument in Russland eskaliert den
Konflikt in der Zeit wo wir keine Kampf
von Schützenpanzer geliefert haben hat
Russland über 40 000 zivile bekämpft
jetzt wo die Diskussion über taur
beginnt und läuft eskaliert Russland
weiter Sprengung des kachowka-staudammes
Zerstörung von Hotels Ermordung jeden
Tag von dutzenden Zivilisten und
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern das bedeutet
also wenn wir wirklich dieser Eskalation
Russlands Einhalt gebieten wollen müssen
wir mit allem reingehen was der
Ausweitung des Krieges entgegenstehen
dass die Taurus auch russisches
können
wir können das ja mit der Ukraine
ausverhandeln und zudem hat selbst der
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius am 20
April deutlich gesagt dass natürlich
auch Versorgungslinien auf russischem
Gebiet bekämpft werden können und müssen
weil es strategisch geboten ist viel
wichtiger ist dass die Ukraine
verhältnismäßig die Waffe einsetzt und
keine zivilen Ziele bekämpft aber
russische Versorgungslinien auf
russischen Gebiet ja selbstverständlich
muss das sein damit die russischen
Versorgungslinien abgeschnitten werden
die russischen Soldaten aufgeben müssen
sie haben schon gesagt Frankreich und
Großbritannien liefern sehr ähnliche
Waffensysteme die USA nicht
normalerweise hätten wir uns immer daran
was die Amerikaner tun oder liefern
sagen Sie in diesem Fall wir sollen uns
da unabhängig machen und liefern egal
was die USA machen die Amerikaner
erwarten von Deutschland mehr
Führungsverantwortung und sie sehen
diese Führungsverantwortung in
Frankreich und Großbritannien der
Bundeskanzler selbst mahnt mehr
europäische deutsche
Führungsverantwortung an aber gerade
hier versteckte sich hinter den
Amerikanern und das ist ja auch sag mal
aus der Sicht eines Außenpolitiker sehr
krit ist der Kanzler wieder in
Abhängigkeit der USA die Amerikaner
werden in einigen Wochen die attackhams
liefern sie werden F16 liefern und dann
klappert Deutschland wieder hinterher
statt dass er jetzt das Feld bereitet
die Taurus vorbereitet werden die
Ausbildung beginnt und er dann
entscheidungsfähig ist verzögert er
wieder und also in dem Punkt also
unabhängig machen von den USA Herr
Kiesewetter lassen sie uns zum Schluss
noch über den mutmaßlichen Spionage Fall
in der Bundeswehr reden in Koblenz wurde
ein Mann festgenommen der beim
Beschaffungsamt der Bundeswehr arbeitet
und mutmaßlich für Russland spioniert
haben soll was ist da passiert wie
besorgniserregendes ist deshalb
besorgniserregend weil es der fünfte
falls seit 2015 ist wo Angehörige von
Sicherheitsbehörden sich freiwillig
Russland angehen und der Kanal
Bundesanwalt hat sich eingeschaltet das
macht nur wenn besondere Staatsschutz
Interessen im Vordergrund stehen
wie sehr hat sich denn ihre Einschätzung
nach die Sicherheitslage in Deutschland
zu allgemein verändert verschlechtert
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser
spricht von einer neuen Dimension durch
Spionage und Cyberangriffe keine neue
Dimension sondern wir sehen das seit
Jahren nicht nur im parlamentarischen
Kontrollgremium wer sicherheitspolitisch
interessiert ist weiß das seit
spätestens 2014 russland sieht uns als
Kriegsziel möchte den Krieg ausweiten
und es ist die Ukraine die verhindert
dass der Krieg sich gegen molder oder
das Baltikum ausweitet also immer wieder
bei Taurus aber eben auch bei
Gegenspionage bei Spionage Abwehr wir
müssen unsere Dienste fitter machen und
auch unsere Bevölkerung finde ich super
dass sie das heute morgen bringen klar
machen dass Russland hier ganz anders
agiert es ist kein Freund kein Partner
es ist ein absoluter Gegner der unsere
Art des Zusammenlebens zerstören will
und dafür auch die AFD nutzt eine extrem
russlandfreundliche rechtsextremistische
Partei die nicht umsonst
beobachtungsvoll ist oder sich diese
Wetter von der CDU war das mit geht im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss vielen Dank für
das Gespräch